[Applause]
hey guys what's up good to see you
excellent
application of the eye black i love it
thanks i did mine in a real macho kind
of way i was like
yeah he was like i don't i want it to
look like i don't care
yeah he went i went low
listen i don't know about you tiki but i
am so excited for this weekend i'm a big
football fan as you know
where will you be watching uh watching
the game i will actually be
in cbs watching it from the broadcast
center i'm gonna be
paying attention as everybody is to the
big stories that are going on around
this game i mean
the super bowl was always fantastic but
this is the first time
that the actual home team is hosting the
super bowl the campaign buccaneers
taking on the defending champion kansas
city chiefs
i can't is that okay that i do that i
can't help but shimmy
i love that it makes me feel good so go
ahead that's what you can do
all right let's talk quarterbacks it's
the buccaneers against the chief this
weekend and everyone's talking about the
goat
tom brady versus the future goat
patrick mahomes now what's the most
exciting thing about this matchup
tiki pat mahomes is the second coming
he's the new
face of football he's he's a
good-looking kid
he's biracial he has already got a super
bowl mvp
a league mvp and he's trying to take tom
brady off of that mantle which he's been
sitting on for two decades now so
it's a great story line it's also going
to be a great matchup as well
patrick mahomes apparently like watched
tom brady when he was six years old
play for the new england patriots and he
really admired him
and so i think that just adds this like
awesome shakespearean
cool level of you're going against
someone that you
idolized as a kid tom brady's never been
more on top of his game
he proved to everyone that is with all
due respect to his team and his coach
that he can do
anything anywhere at any time and so
i think the pairing and i know tom brady
has said just the nicest things about
patrick mahomes
so if you love but you're having to you
know
fight it's just like oh it's just so
rich
and i'm so excited and it's all about
legacy i think this is tom brady's 10th
super bowl it could be his seventh win
or patrick could get a second win in a
row and i think the history will be made
in the super bowl not only in the game
but during the halftime show as well
tiki we know the week the weekend is
pulling out all the stops for this
performance he spent like seven million
dollars of his own money to make it
amazing
um and pepsi just released a little
promo this is a glimpse take a look
we're seeing this for the first time
what we
create changes us
every performance a new chapter
[Music]
every stage a new beginning
i think it's going to be great to you
and you've been to super bowls before
what do you think makes a great halftime
show
i think that the energy and the the the
performers who
come and they give it to everybody there
now the crowd is only going to be 22 000
it's not going to be full capacity
but i think everybody's going to be
excited about the weekend but
it's a good thing it's not on a monday
because the weekend would have made
sense
look at you tiki with a joke it could be
a three-day
most people take monday off anyways
right right nobody knows what the days
of the weeks are
anymore um all right we have to talk
about
the main event uh which is the other
main event
i'm a big football fan and i love the
super bowl and i watch it every year but
i also
love the commercials and this year it's
going to be different because
biggies like budweiser are sitting out
and donating the money instead to
vaccination programs but we still got
some surprises
and we're going to look at a sneak peek
at one uh right now amazon is
relaunching their
alexa with a brand new shape and look
and they premiere this steamy ad on
sunday everybody guys
yeah alexa
[Music]
alexa no don't do that
alexa do that i mean i'm like
uh it was a michael b jordan right yes
tiki what do you think when you see it
look are they are they gonna allow alexa
to take on the voices of some of these
stars because i know
and patrick dempsey is my wife's like it
guy and he's filming something in new
jersey right now so i'm like don't go
over don't go don't go over there you
don't need to go watch you don't need to
go
that actually made me a little
uncomfortable i fell for the husband
it's probably not for a straight mail
that said
i will say this um i am terrified like i
have my siri
off her and i aren't besties anyway i am
orwellian
phobic i don't want stuff being listened
to in my house i'm not into the
orwellian like
voice mechanisms in my house so when you
sell it as michael b
jordan it makes it a little more
enticing yeah how you listen to him for
sure
before we go we're gonna do a rush of
fun facts about the super bowl
oh fun well there you go okay tikki
you're our quarterback
so three two one hike it
here we go all right here's the first
one for you drew and ross
first this is the most viewed halftime
show
of all time is it a lady gaga b
janet and justin or c
katy perry okay so i want to see lady
gaga
because you know it's the most recent of
the three but i think it's
uh justin and janet that was the one
everyone talked about remember
i'm gonna go a gaga okay i'm gonna go
it's weird because we always pick the
same thing
okay what is it tiki you're both wrong
it's katy perry
100 20 million viewers lady gaga was a
close second
with 117 million viewers i think youtube
of janet and
uh and justin that was probably like
five billion views but
yeah next one 52 of people surveyed say
that they will give up
this for their team if they if their
team could win
the big game um is the answer a their
annual bonus b
a year of vacation days or c
their entire 401k i have to think it's
vacation days right are you giving up
money for your team to win
i'll go with you rossie on vacation day
your luck assistant you're
congratulations 52 of people
say that they would give up vacation
days 31
said their annual bonus and only 3 given
up their 401ks
yeah all right because i like the
seahawks but i like the coin too
all right last one for you guys by the
numbers this is the most
popular halftime super bowl snack
is it a pigs in a blanket b
wings or c pizza i think it has to be b
wings everyone's in the mood for wings
on super bowl sunday b wings
okay congratulations you're both correct
it is b
wings 1.4 billion
wings will be consumed on sunday did you
say 1.4 billion wings
1.4 billion 1.4 billion now
we're still trying to clarify that's a
lot alexa can you
divide that by two um i i have to say
that this was so fun and we've been
looking forward to this all week tiki
and we can't wait for the big game and
we'll be with you in spirit and
um just thank you so much tiki barbara
thank you tiki great to see you great to
see you guys again
[Music]